wowzer wowzer wowza this next comic on
the bananamore stage really
pushes the envelope and you know now
that i'm saying that i don't know what
that statement means
but please welcome anna
[Applause]
how's it going um so
i uh yeah so i i'm not like a comedian
per se
uh i am uh i would say funny um
definitely around the house um but
anyway no
but uh but honestly i'm not uh i'm a
record guy i'm not like a
you know a joke kind of guy
uh so i i wanted originally to do a
little show-and-tell
um this is a classic record serge
gainsberg
no problems kind of the very decent
piece um
yeah but i guess not about that my
girlfriend's in the room um her name is
savannah
and um she's encouraging me she
submitted me for this and she said
you're so funny around the house i go
come on you know but so she said just do
your jokes like you do with me so i
i guess i guess i'll be doing
pretty much that okay so
normally i'm a crate digger which is
somebody who
digs records i mean it's kind of inside
term but
but i guess after today i'll be changing
um
my profession to a grave digger because
you guys are going to die
from laughter is
uh did someone laugh
okay so it is recording right just
uh yeah so yeah uh anyway so i wrote
some jokes down if
um these uh she says that my jokes about
jazz are a little too divisive
uh i go what are they uh keith jarrett
records nah i'm just kidding
anyway so i'm gonna do the kindness she
said do the cassavetes of jokes you know
jokes that are for everybody you know
not appreciated in their own lifetime
but
so okay so this is a kind of everyday
joke
um so uh but the other day my girlfriend
savannah
um she she i went to use a pot and i
i see that she used the pot that she
used which had lentils in it
um she left it to soak i go why
savannah i call her in the room i go
savannah come back you know
you don't wash the pot you know and she
goes i just got to let it soak in i go
let it soak in what is this
the philip glass concert i attended in
1989
in switzerland is someone laughing
because
i'm sitting in the coffee yeah i thought
someone left but savannah coughed
okay we all remember um this is a
relatable joke sansa's 2020 right we all
kind of
um remember am i supposed to look here
or there
or what right here right okay so yeah
since it's 20 20
who can forget um so uh am i gonna go to
jail because i lied
on the census 201 that's a question i
have for everybody tonight
am i gonna go to jail cause i wrote down
that i have a roommate but it turns out
i actually have a beautiful
woman who is my girlfriend her name's
savannah so
all right so i'm going to wrap it up
here and um i guess i will leave with a
classic jazz joke which is uh
a lot of people go new orleans or new
york you love jazz new orleans new york
i go new question i love it all anyway
thank you so much
savannah was that pretty good or are you
laughing i don't know she has a threat
but she's a pain yep um
okay i'm gonna get some done
[Applause]
[Applause]
laugh at your screen
thanks for coming to bananamores
you